so right over here figure B is a scaled
copy of figure a and what we want to do
is figure out what is the scale factor
to go from figure a to figure B pause
the video and see if you can figure that
out well all we have to do is look at
corresponding sides and think about how
much they have been scaled by so for
example this side right over here would
correspond to this side right over here
on Figure B and over here it had length
2 and over here it has length 1 2 3 4 5
6 so it looks like that side has been
scaled up by a factor of 3 and so if
this and figure B truly is a scaled copy
then every side should be scaled up by a
factor of 3 and we could verify that we
don't do it with every side we're being
told that these are scaled copies but we
can see that this is the case for
example this side right over here
corresponds to this base right over here
this has length 3 so if we're scaling up
by a factor of 3 we should multiply that
by 3 and this should be of length 9
let's see if that's the case 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 and 9 and so you can see we can feel
pretty good that Figure B is a scaled
copy of figure a and that scaling factor
is 3